hot breath angel angel perez
how do you control your ego um how do
you keep yourself grounded
so you can stay objectionable and keep
your edge
well i try not to have an ego um i think
you have to have an
arrogance about yourself when you go on
stage you have to be arrogant enough to
believe that what you have to say is so
important that everybody has to shut the
up to hear it
there's arrogance in that but i don't
know
i've worked with enough comics who used
to have the juice that don't have the
juice no more
and not wanting that for myself is
more than enough to try and keep me
humble because the people that are
coming up behind you are the ones that
are eventually going to leapfrog you
that's inevitable you leapfrog and then
you get leapfrogged and
the goal for me at least once
tv is done with me on camera
is to try to create and write content
and produce content and if not that at
least tour
you know you look at a like
sinbad sinbad
hasn't been with the exception of the
sitcom
rail on fox before that sinbad wasn't on
tv on a regular enough basis
but his entire career he sells tickets
every year
as if the was on tv
yesterday and i believe i truly believe
a lot of that
is from being kind and of course being
funny
but just never carrying yourself with an
air of arrogance you know
treat other comedians as your peers and
not your peons
you'll be all right